what up space fam golsan here from anime
uproar back at it again with a brand new
naruto video about every kange known to
man
quite the undertaking but you guys
definitely deserve it after we hit over
6 000 likes on the all akatsuki members
and their powers explained video
similarly smash that like button this
time and let's try to get 6 000 likes on
this one as well
to unlock the next naruto video these
videos take a bunch of time and effort
so i really appreciate it when you guys
show your support through destroying
that like button
and also leaving suggestions for future
naruto videos below
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future naruto
videos and while you wait for the next
video to drop
be sure to check out my growing naruto
playlist which includes videos about the
hokage
all otsutsuki aluzumaki and much much
more
now without further ado let's get into
it spoilers and all
so in this video we are going to be
looking at every kage from each of the
five villages
this includes all the kazekage meaning
wind shadow from tsunagakure
aka the village hidden in the sand all
the mizukage meaning water shadow
from kirigakure aka the village hit in
the mist
all the rai kage meaning lightning
shadow from
kumo gakurei aka the village hidden the
clouds
all the tsuchikage meaning earth shadow
from iwagakure
aka the village hidden in the stones and
of course all the hokage meaning fire
shadow from kona hagakure
aka the village hidden the leaves so
we're going to cover
every known kage or leader from these
five key hidden villages
each of which corresponds to one of the
five great shinobi countries
in general the kage is the strongest
shinobi of the continent
and is charged with leading and
protecting their village the first ever
kage was hashirama senju who was elected
after the formation of konoha
and eventually other nations were like
hey that's a cool system and adopted it
for themselves we will start this video
with the kazekage from the village
hidden in the sand
the first stone kazekage was reto and he
founded the village hidden in the sand
he was strong and it's said that he used
his overwhelming power to get all of his
nation's ninja
under his control unfortunately we do
not know much
more about reto except that he was
present at the first gokage
summit and that he went in order to ask
for more fertile land for his people
we know he was assassinated and many
kazekage
would go on to share the same fate
leading people to believe that the
kazikage were cursed
reito was followed by shamon the second
kazikage
he stands out a lot with his mostly bald
head and
a giant dragon looking tattoo covering
it the dragon's claw actually covered
the dude's eye
in a data book it was revealed that he
was into researching jin churiki
with the hope of increasing his
village's power once again we don't know
a lot about the specifics of shimon's
power but
we do know that he used puppets in
battle and so he was a kind of precursor
for sasuri and kankuro he was clearly
strong
since he was picked as kazekage and
since he was appointed to go with the
first kazekage to the gokage summit
it is also noteworthy that under his
rule there was military expansion and
groundbreaking advancement further
suggesting that he was a powerful man
and one good at military strategy as
well
like his predecessor he fell victim to
an assassination the third kasikage was
considered to be exceptionally strong
stronger than both of his predecessors
according to sasuri the third kazikage's
iron sand technique made his name the
most powerful of all
the third was intelligent enough to
develop his iron sand technique
after examining the one tails power his
keke genkai
magnet release let him convert his
chalker into magnetic force
allowing him to manipulate the iron
powder in his iron sand
thus he could perform his own unique
version of sand manipulation the third's
magnet powers also made metallic weapons
useless against him furthermore
he could use his sand to jam up the
puppets of his enemies
so you know he would have done very well
against the second kazukage as cheo
pointed out this iron sand technique
wasn't just praised
it was considered to be the most feared
weapon in the village's
history eventually the third kazikage
was somehow beat by the akatsuki's very
own sasuri he turned the third into one
of his human puppets
and it was his favorite because of how
hard it was to attain
in the anime the kazikage's magnet
release was more powerful than that of
sasuri's puppet which could also use the
unique
genka so yeah at the end of the day he
was used to hype up sasuri but this dude
was clearly a legend
and a very interesting character in
naruto's history and i would have loved
to see the fight between the third
kazikage and sasuri i'm sure it was
amazing but for now let's move on to the
fourth kazekage and a contender for the
worst dad in all of anime
rasa aka gara's dad rasa turned his son
into a jinchuriki by placing the one
tails aka shukaku
inside him and then wanted to
assassinate him when kidgara failed to
practice complete control over his
emotions and over shukaku
because of his father gara thought that
no one loved him for a long time and
it's understandable that a kid
who thought no one loved him would get
emotional but beyond his flawed
parenting
there are some interesting aspects to
rasa's powers rasa
learned the third's magnet release which
is a combination of earth release and
wind release
he used this magnet style to control
gold dust as rasa himself explains when
he's brought back for a bit
gold dust is heavier than sand if mixed
the gold dust can slow the sand down
this is how he'd counter gotta sand and
stop
shukaku the sand spirit when he started
running amuck
he could use his gold dust to form an
eye to monitor
different locations and in general he
could use the sand bending moves we're
used to seeing with his gold dust
like creating waves out of it raising it
for defensive purposes and launching
swift attacks with it
it was also revealed that he was skilled
in water release and could create a
water blade that could actually cut
through the so-called absolute defense
aka the shield of sand no small feat in
a data book it was revealed
that he was capable of using yen release
and with that
we move on to the fifth kage on this
list the final kazukage
my boy gotta gara is such a good example
of the shonen trope that involves a
crazy seemingly irredeemable villain
becoming a good guy and friend i
remember
hating and being freaked out by gara
during the tuning exams and thanks to
the great writing i
changed my mind about him and realized
that he acted like that because of his
upbringing
and when offered a chance to change he
took it gara's character arc is
undoubtedly one of the most touching and
powerful ones in naruto
and it's fun to see how he pretty much
accomplishes naruto's own goal before
him by becoming the kagi of his own
village
before even naruto does thus giving
naruto more motivation
and an example to move toward and get
inspired by
but anyways enough of my fanboying over
gara
let's turn to his powers as a kid garo
was killing the assassins that were
trying to kill him and we all know how
much
gara was hyped up during the tuning
exams he set the record for completing
the force of death
and came out of it unscratched looking
at his childhood it's no surprise
that he was strong enough to become the
fifth kasich
and he did possess the one-tailed
shukaku which obviously
increased his power as well when his
father is brought back with the edo
tensei
along with some other kage gara who is
the commander-in-chief of the allied
shinobi forces combat divisions at the
time
is strong enough to defeat him gara can
use earth lightning and wind release and
magnet release as well
he can use magnet release to increase
the density of his sand
which can be especially useful for
creating a strong defense then of course
there's gara's sand bending and sand
manipulation i know this is an avatar
the last airbender but you will
catch me calling people earthbenders
waterbenders and so on for every series
and that pretty much means people who
can manipulate that element in
question argara is a sand bender in this
sense
in his gourd he has personal sand with
his own chakra that he could use
quicker but he can also use surrounding
sand or break down surrounding earth
into sand
even after shukaku is taken from his
body
gara can continue to manipulate large
amounts of sand without a noticeable
difference
then there are moves like sand binding
coffin where
gara surrounds and traps his opponents
with sand he can then let them suffocate
or use sand burial to make the sand
contract
and kill them instantly and as mentioned
there is gara's absolute defense
which includes his shield of sand that
automatically protects him
it's actually his mother's doing even
after her death
she continues to protect him like she
promised to do
and that's just so heartwarming to know
especially after gara's horrible
upbringing then there's an armor of sand
that protects his body
if people somehow manage to get past
this automatic shield
the dude can even manipulate enough sand
to protect his entire village from
daedalus bomb
a most impressive feat furthermore gara
can use his sand to fly
create sand clones create a third spying
eye and more
another hype technique is the grand sand
mausoleum seal
that can trap very powerful opponents
and seal them within a pyramid of sand
when gaara was a jinchuriki shukaku
could take over his body when gara was
under enough stress or fell asleep then
it would transform into his giant
one-tails form
and as previously mentioned run him up
obviously being a jean churiki is always
a nice power boost but interestingly
enough
gara is still very powerful without
shukaku so much so that people
mistakenly assume that he's still a jin
chuniki sometimes
in the third data book his stats were as
follows a five
in ninjutsu a two in thai jutsu a 3.5 in
genjutsu
a four in intelligence a 2.5 in strength
a 3 in speed a 5 in stamina and a 4
enhanced seals giving him an overall
score of 29 out of 40. i'll mention
stats when we have access to them as
with gara
but sometimes we won't and in those
cases i'll just move straight on to the
next
kage so now that we've finished looking
at all of the kazekage let's move on to
the mizukage or water shadows from
kirigakure
in the land of water the first mizukage
was biakuren
and he founded the village hid in the
mist he rocked a long
grey beard and had a scar over his left
eye and he appears to have been blind in
that eye
with his old wise man appearance it
won't come as a surprise that he was
praised for his worldly wisdom
he too was present at the first gokage
summit during the first shinobi war and
he was not happy when he heard some of
the first kazikage's
seemingly greedy demands unfortunately
we don't know much more about him
other than he'd probably get along well
with the old wise man of avatar uncle
iro
since even the word byakuren translates
to white lotus
so these two wise old dudes would be
destined to hit it off i feel like we
also know he must have been powerful
since he was able to not only become a
mizukage but also create kirigakura in
the first place as well
the second mizukage was gengetsuhozuki
he was a member of the hozuki clan
and look like someone you don't want to
mess with by the way the hozuki clan
are known for their ability to turn
their solid bodies into liquid it's sort
of like
having a water logia power in one piece
where you can turn parts of your body
liquid so physical attacks don't hurt
you
gengetsu would also clash with the
second tsuchikage
more on him later and they would both
end up killing each other
in their final exchange he also knew old
man onoki the third tsuchikage when he
was young
and used to pick on him which is pretty
hilarious when he was brought
back by the edo tensei he almost killed
onoki
with the hozuki's clan's water gun jutsu
but luckily
garo was quick enough to save him
gengetsu was very impressed by his
fellow browless kage
and said gaara would go on to do big
things
gara and friends had a lot of trouble
defeating him when he was temporarily
brought back to life
he knew water lightning earth and fire
release and yin and yang release
as mentioned he could turn his body into
liquid and back as he wished and fire
his very deadly water gunjutsu
gengetsu's body was also a mixture of
water
and oil a kind of oil that made normal
sand attacks practically useless against
him then there was his very powerful
steam imp clone
that would heat up before exploding and
cool down again and repeat the process
until it was stopped that's why it was
called gengetsu's
infinite explosion in jutsu eventually
gara had to use his
father's gold dust in order to stop
gengetsu and his steam imp
since the gold would be melted and then
welded onto the clone
so it would be slower and to boot since
gold has good thermal conductivity it
prevented it from heating up enough to
explode again
gengetsu called gara a golden child
after he used that impressive strategy
and i loved that pun but at the same
time if his father hadn't been brought
back
they would have been in big trouble
overall gengetsu was
strong and very cool but let's move on
to the third mizukage now
this long dark-haired man accompanied
the first mizukage to the first gokage
summit during the first shinobi war
unfortunately we don't know much about
him except that he was probably the
strongest shinobi in kirigakure while he
was kage
and that he was strong enough to serve
as the first mizukage's bodyguard during
the gokage summit and that about covers
it for this
unnamed man but that's one of the
reasons naruto is so good even though we
know next to nothing about this guy you
just know that he probably has a very
interesting story behind him and i would
actually love to read about it if it
ever came out in a bonus or side story
but for now we move on to the fourth
mizukage
who has a name and it is yagura
karatachi
yagura was no joke despite his youthful
appearance and despite getting genjutsu
pretty hard by obito as a child
he partook in his village's ritual where
academy students were forced to murder
one another in order to graduate
like naruto and gara yagura was a kage
and jin churiki specifically the three
tales jin churiki
not only that he was one of the first
people to gain complete control over a
tailed beast
in fact he became a perfect jin churiki
at a young age
and in the anime he fought akatsuki
members juzo
and hitachi and managed to actually kill
juzo one of the seven legendary
swordsmen of the mist
and hitachi only managed to stop him by
using a matarasu
notably yagura's weapon of choice was a
sort of staff
with a hook at each end yagura could use
water release and wind release
in the anime as well one of yagura's
most interesting techniques was his
ability to create water mirrors that
reflect the enemy's attack
literally the reflection actually
materializes from the mirror and the
enemy's exact same technique is used
against them
in this way yagura can completely cancel
out other people's attacks
with his perfect jin churiki control he
could undergo partial transformations
or enter full 3 tails mode he could also
launch biju balls
and use the coral palm technique which
causes coral to quickly form around the
opponent from the point of contact
causing them to lose mobility and
although there's more i could say about
this kange
of the bloody mist for the purpose of
this video we should be moving on to the
next kage
mizukage number five mei terumi yagura's
bloody reign wasn't really viewed as a
positive one
so mei spent a lot of time on reform and
fixing relations with other villages
she also went through the deadly academy
graduation ritual
of her own village she's the first
kunoichi or female ninja will be
covering
and when you have a female kage naruto
you know she's gonna be pretty strong
she can use water earth fire and
lightning release
but what's really interesting is that
she has access to two keke genkai
including lava release which combines
earth and fire release and boil release
which combines fire and water release
boil release creates a mist capable of
melting bodies and even melting sasuke
susano which is supposed to be an
absolute defense
mei is seemingly immune to the mist but
it's indiscriminate for everyone else
and so has to be used when there are no
allies around
and lava release is pretty much lava
bending which is just as dope in the
naruto world
as it is in the avatar world it's also
notable that
mei could use water style to not only
defend against madara's firestyle attack
but she could then go on to use that
same body of water to form
an attacking water dragon the transition
from defense to attack is seamless
and i love it lastly she can use the
hidden missed
jutsu in order to obscure her own
movements and that of her allies like
zabuza did against kakashi
the cool thing is this jutsu can counter
the shotting god
and rinagon's perceptiveness but in the
anime byakugan users can still see
through the mist
and sensors can still locate people too
next after the dangerously hot mate
terumi
we got the sixth mizukage jojuro who is
also a member of the seven ninja
swordsman of the mist
he went from simping hard over the fifth
mizukage to becoming a mizukage himself
although he may not look it at first
glance jojoro is
actually pretty awesome even among the
seven swordsmen of the mist
jojo is considered to be a master
swordsman in the boruto anime he fought
against three opponents wielding blades
of the hidden mist
and he beat them using only a broken
katana he also proceeded to lift the
very heavy
kubikiri bocho aka zabuza's blade
effortlessly with one hand with gara's
help
jojoro also fared well during an
encounter with urashiki
otsutsuki and boruto and being able to
not get completely flexed on by
nototookie is always noteworthy
chojiro's blade is called hiramekare the
flat fish
it can store chakra which can later be
released
the chakra surrounds the blade and can
take on any shape the user wishes
for instance against sasuke chojiro
shaped it into
a hammer that sent sasuke flying even
though he had susanoo's ribs activated
against black zetsu his blade unleashed
a huge
chakra slash that left black satsu
unable to move
and even naruto had to admit that jojoro
was good
bystanders were impressed not only by
the size of his sword but also
by his skill in wielding it black zetsu
was surprised by how
trojaro could transform the shape of his
blade so fast
the two handle sword can also be split
into two swords
with one handle each if you want to
throw in some two sword style moves
beyond that the sword can use the bone
mutilation technique
this technique launches chakra needles
at the opponent these needles disrupt
the chakra pathway system and slowly
kill the target
lastly chojiro is only known to use
water release but he is very skilled
at it if he doesn't have a sword on him
he can create a water blade
which is handy because he's easily one
of the most killed swordsmen in naruto
so yeah i hope that i helped get across
how trojan is actually pretty strong and
cool but
now we must move on to the rai kage of
kumo gakure
aka the village hidden in the clouds and
these guys are definitely some of the
coolest kage around
hey the first try kage and get used to
hearing the name a because we'll hear
that a lot
found in the village of kumo gakurei it
was this reikage
who seemingly sent the gold and silver
brothers to capture the nine tails
before moderate tamed it
though they failed if things did go down
like this it was a strategic idea
because the power of the nine tails
would dramatically increase
the military power of any nation we
don't know much else
other than that he was present at the
first gokage summit
and he had to be very strong in order to
form and then rule over a powerful
shinobi village
the second reikage also called a was the
long time bodyguard of the first
again info is lacking but he had to be
powerful to be chosen as a bodyguard of
the first raikkage
and then to be chosen as the second
reichage he was also good
at the political side of things and was
known for doing a lot in order to
achieve peace
it was actually during a formal ceremony
that cemented the alliance between
konoha
and kumo gakure that a and the second
hokage
were attacked by the gold and silver
brothers although tsunade mentions that
the brothers drove the second hokage
close to the brink of death it's not
made clear what happened to a
moving on to a number three aka the
third raikhange who is said to be the
greatest reikage of all
he was said to have an invincible spear
and an impenetrable shield
and naruto had to actually use the
third's
own spear aka his own attack to
penetrate through his incredible defense
thus showing that his spear was stronger
than his shield
still it's pretty cool when you're so
strong that only you can hurt you
and i haven't even mentioned his
remarkable speed
that impressed all those who witnessed
it this dude is as legendary as they
come
he faced ten thousand ninja for three
days and three nights
in order to help his people get away
from the enemy he was also able to go
head to head with the eight tails
unarmored and unarmed
and the scar he ended up with was
self-inflicted but let's get into some
specific abilities the third could use
lightning fire and earth release
he was known for his black lightning
which he passed on to darui
he could also use lightning release
chakra mode aka cloak himself in
lightning which increased his speed
reaction time attack and defense
lightning release chakra mode is fast
enough to dodge amaterasu we're told
that not even the shoting gun can keep
up with this technique when it is used
by the fourth raikage
besides that we're told that long range
wind release attacks
are the only ones that can reach the
third reikage but even they cannot give
him a decisive blow
and then there's his strongest ninjutsu
which allowed him to pull
lightning chakra into his fingertips and
the less fingers he used the more
focused and thus powerful the technique
was this technique is so
sharp that it can even pierce through a
rubber wall even though rubber is
resistant to electricity the attack was
called an
invincible spear and as i mentioned it
was even stronger than his famously
strong and sturdy body
and as a result it was the key to
beating him now although i feel like i
could talk about this legend all day
let's move on to the fourth raikage and
the fourth a
a number four is the son of the third
reikage and he does not disappoint this
dude is so cool at one point he just
cuts off his arm that's been hit with
amaterasu like it's no big deal he was
also elected to be the supreme leader of
the allied shinobi forces a title that
you'd expect to go to someone who is
extremely strong
similar to the third he combines
ninjutsu and tai jutsu
making use of the lightning release
chakra mode in order to enhance his
speed attack and defense before naruto
surpassed him a was the self-proclaimed
fastest shinobi in the world since
minato passed away
karen also mentioned that his chakra
levels were through the roof comparable
to that of a tailed beast his fight
against sasuke was absolutely amazing
and although amaterasu who did
eventually prove to be effective against
him the fourth reikage clearly had
sasuke on the defense
and he was so strong that he was able to
break through the so-called absolute
defense
that is susanoo's ribcage the fourth
reikage could use lightning earth and
water release and it's worth mentioning
that sasuke's chidori which would have
killed most people
left the fourth practically unfazed all
in all this guy was very fast very cool
and very strong
just like his father this lightning
shadow didn't fall far from the
lightning tree
lastly among the reikage there is darui
and for once not another a da'roi was
the right-hand man to the fourth
before he inherited the title of kage
and daruei was also skilled enough to
play the biggest role
in beating the very powerful gold and
silver brothers
and obviously he continued to get
stronger and more skilled until he
eventually became the fifth raikage
the dude also has insane chakra levels
as seen when he was able to use
multiple treasured tools that belong to
the sage of six paths
and continues to fight effectively even
one could kill a normal person because
of how much chakra these tools consume
when it comes to releases the rooi can
use wind water and of course lightning
one of my favorite combos has the rui
use a water wall technique
that he combines with lightning release
in order to electrocute his trap target
then there's storm release which is a
combination of lightning and water
and allows him to fire and control beams
of electricity that flow like water
then as mentioned there's black
lightning that he inherited from the
third reichage he can form a black
panther made of lightning
that will shock any target it comes into
contact with
darui is also very skilled with his
signature cleaver sword
he can run lightning based chakra
through the sword to increase its
destructive power the blade maintains
its charge even when darui
isn't holding it and that's it for the
raika game as a fanboy of lightning
based powers i gotta say i love the
raikage but the time has come to move on
to the tsuchikage
or earth shadow of iwagakure there have
been
four thus far starting with the first
ishikawa
who founded iwagakure in the land of
earth
according to the anime ishikawa was a
member of the kamizuru clan
a clan known for controlling bees of
course he attended the first kage summit
he also contained sacred scrolls about
bug taming arts in the anime and before
the series of naruto bugs didn't seem
that interesting or cool to me at all
but you gotta admit that shino aburama
proved that they could be quite deadly
indeed some cool facts about this
kange are that he could use earth
release to fly
and as mentioned it suggested that he
used insect-based ninjutsu but
as usual we don't know much more about
the first
except that he was strong enough to
create his own village moving on to the
second tuchikage moo
the cool mummy looking kage he was known
as the non-person or the null man
because according to kabuto he had
neither form nor
chakra suggesting he was kind of like
the invisible man
not leaving a trace moo was killed
enough to kill the second mizukage
although mu
was also killed in return moo was very
skilled in terms of being able to sense
chakra from great distances
and being able to identify people in
different populations based on their
chakra signatures being able to sense
chakra so well
also allowed him to dodge enemy attacks
even if they were coming from his blind
spot
he could split in two and avoid lethal
or sealing attacks but this would also
cut his power in half not surprisingly
this non-person was practically
impossible to detect through normal
means to the point where it is
impressive if someone does discover his
presence he is one of the few shinobi
who had access to all five nature
transformations including yang released
he could use earth release to fly
and water release to hide his presence
by bending light
such a cool ability that uriah would
love to have for obvious reasons but as
if all of this
including flying and being invisible
wasn't enough he also had access to dust
release
or particle style a combination of earth
wind and fire release
this release consists of forming a cube
and releasing it at the enemy the cube
grows in size and will automatically
dismantle anything it touches including
people's bodies at a near
molecular level thus turning them into
dust this technique is so powerful that
it could be easily used to fight off
large enemy numbers all in all dust
release is one of the best techniques in
naruto and moo
is definitely one of my favorite kage i
would have loved to see more of him
doing his thing in his own time
but for now let's move on to the third
tsuchikage
our old boy onoki an over 80 year old
man that still kicks butt
what's not to love don't let his back
pain fool you he
saved the raikage against madara and
even madara had to praise this old timer
at one point singling him out as the
problem among all five cogging onoki can
use earth fire lightning wind and yang
release
but what's even more interesting is that
according to the novels he can use
lava release and like the previously
mentioned kage he can definitely use
dust or particle style release as
mentioned with particle style
he could turn anything in his path into
dust at least
if they don't have hex abilities that
can absorb jutsu's his particle style is
said to be able to destroy an
entire island even daeda is impressed by
such destructive potential there's so
much
other great stuff about this old legend
he is exceptionally skilled at earth
released and he can use it to fly
create clones or even large rock golems
furthermore
in a very earth-bending-esque way he can
encase his fist in rock in order to
increase the power of his punches and he
can increase
and decrease the weights of objects as
he sees fit
so you can increase the weight of rock
punches or he can increase the weight of
other things to slow opponents down
or as already mentioned decreases weight
in order to fly
all in all i love this awesome old
earthbender and he would also fit in
very well within the avatar world
just gonna put that out there then
there's the fourth and latest tsuchikage
kurotsuchi she is the granddaughter of
onoki and
related to the first suchikage as well
when her grandpa retired which is
understandable at his age i think he
deserved it
kurotsuchi took the reigns it's
definitely hard not to live in her
grandfather's earth shadow but she is
strong in her own right
she can use earth fire and water release
as well as yin release in the novels
she is hyped up by a legend in boruto
that she didn't flinch in the face
of 100 000 zetsu in the four shinobi war
her earthbending two is impressive as
she can create powerful rock shelters
for defense deadly spears from the earth
that could impale a target dracula style
and she could just plain old hide in the
ground as well she could also unearth
other people or things hiding in the
ground
so good luck holding your ground against
her she is a master of lava release and
can use it in conjunction with water
release to create quick lime that can
trap opponents
like quick drying cement and so we've
covered all the different
kage except the hokage from konoha and
since i said i'll cover takagi in this
video
i will quickly go through these as well
but i do suggest that you check out my
all seven hokage and their powers
explain video where you'll get a more
detailed breakdown of each hokage
number one is the man the myth the
legend the one known as the god of
shinobi hashirama
senju the founder of the hidden leaf
village with his friend and rival madara
he was considered to be the strongest
shinobi of his era
period which is saying a lot he was
stronger than madara
and madara could take on 5 kage on his
own pretty easily
so it goes to show the power gap that
there can be between
kage so saying someone is kage level may
imply a base of strength but that range
can vary greatly
there is much that can be said but
hashirama is mostly known for his wood
release
his cells that everyone wants a piece of
to enhance their own powers
and for being another reincarnation of
asura tsutsuki just like naruto the
second hokage was tobi rama sendru the
little brother of hashirama
although he was less powerful he did
have his strengths
toby rama was fast and strong enough to
kill madara's brother
izuna uchiha which kind of makes you
feel bad for those chihas who keep
losing in these matchups
toby ramos astronomy shinobi in konoha
during his time as hokage
and he even survived an encounter with
the gold and silver's brothers with
their nine tails chakra
and treasured sage of six paths tools he
eventually sacrificed his life to help
his team escape
alive and name sarutobi his successor
some highlights include the fact that he
created the shadow clones technique
specialized in water release techniques
and excelled in space-time ninjutsu
he created the flying thunder god
technique that minato was famous for
mastering as well
and this allowed both to mark a spot
which could be a person's body even and
then teleport themselves and or
other things to that spot another fun
thing to do
is to throw a marked kunai to get across
a battlefield extremely quickly
and lastly i'll mention that the genius
toby rama also created the edo tensei
or impure world reincarnation technique
that orochimaru was so into
it straight up returned the souls of
dead people and put them in regenerating
bodies
quite the insane technique and we have
tobi rama to thank for it
albeit orochimaru did improve on this
forbidden technique
so there's more that can be said but
toby rama for me is mostly remembered as
an innovator
who created many techniques that would
go on to be used and refined by others
after his death hokage number three was
hirozen
sarutobi also referred to as the god of
shinobi
when the series began this is the old
dude that was serving as hokage
he was the most powerful kangi of his
lifetime not only that
iruka sensei lets us know that he was
nicknamed the professor
and that even compared to the other kage
which at this point
included the first to fourth sarutobi
was said to have possessed superlative
strength which would suggest that he was
at least the second strongest of the
four
if not the first obviously this could be
iruka
hyping him up and public perception
doesn't always reflect reality but the
fact that only hashirama and sarutobi
were called
god of shinobi definitely suggest that
they were the two strongest out of the
four
he was so strong that even as an old man
he managed to stop arochimaru who had
the help of the reincarnated first and
second hokage
that was probably one of the most
legendary fights slash moments in naruto
and even in anime in general if a
legendary character has to die
that's the way to do it ano rochimaru
pretty much admitted that if sarutobi
was 10 years younger
he would have killed rochimaru but this
should also add to a respect to the over
80 year old onoki
since saratobi was 69 when he died
sarutobi was known as the professor
because of his vast
knowledge and it was said that he could
use any technique
he was known for his personal summon
enema the monkey king the monkey king
could transform into an extendable staff
aka power pole
that was as hard as diamond it was
sadotobi's weapon of choice
although it was heavy and the weight did
become more of an issue as he got older
so clearly you have journeyed to the
west and dragon ball vibes when it comes
to sodor toby and his monkey king summon
lastly i'll mention the op dead demon
consuming seal
and uzumaki clan technique that allowed
sarutobi
to call upon a shinigami then in
exchange for the user so the shinigami
will seal the target soul
what's crazy is that you could replace
your real body with a shadow clone
and still use this technique so if
sarutobi was younger
and he had more chakra for more shadow
clones he could have sealed
rochimaru's abilities or even his entire
soul
without actually sacrificing his own
life when used
orochimaru didn't even know a technique
like this existed
and that's saying a lot since orochimaru
was very well versed in techniques
including forbidden jutsu and the other
cool thing is there's no telling how
many more techniques sarutobi knew about
moving on to the fourth hokage naruto's
dad minato namikaze
the yellow flash jiraiya called minato a
rare genius the kind you don't see very
often
and as the fourth ride kage mentioned he
believed he was the fastest shinobi
after minato's death
acknowledging that minotau was faster
than even him one of my favorite details
about minato
is that villagers told their shinobi to
flee the moment they saw minato
during the third shinobi war that's how
dangerous this dude was
and he died bravely saving the village
from a disguised obito
and the nine tails it was wish that he
was there when orochimaru attacked the
village
suggesting that he would have been able
to deal with the powerful villain better
than anyone
else i always liked the idea of having
super speed as a super power when i was
a kid which adds to how much i like
minato
because he'd pretty much take down
enemies as soon as they saw him if not
sooner he was similar to naruto in that
he could summon
gamabunta the chief toad and use the
rasengan which he actually developed
after observing
tailed beast bombs the rasengan was
perfect for him because it complemented
his fast fighting style
due to it not requiring hand seals as
mentioned
he not only learned the second hokage's
flying thunder god technique but honed
and improved upon it to the point
where he had greater mastery over it
than its creator toby rama even admitted
that minato
was better at teleporting than him and
one of the most epic fight moments in
the series was
when he used the technique against obito
a teleportation master in his own right
and caught him off guard by teleporting
to where his marked airborne kunai was
he then immediately launched a
devastating lasengan he also managed to
mark obito's body without obito noticing
and eventually forced ochiha to retreat
but not before he freed the nine tails
from obito's control
and i really like how it was shown that
minotau was faster than
all three previous hokage when they were
all brought back
with the edo tensing lastly we can
mention how minato became ajinchuriki
of the yen half of the nine tails right
before he died
when he was brought back with the edo
tensei he could actually enter nine
tails chakra mode
in this form he could straight up launch
tailed beast bombs
and do all the fun stuff naruto can do
and we should be moving on but i also
wanna just point out that minotau was
very very smart to the point where he
had the highest scores in academy
history
so in this sense naruto definitely
wasn't a chip off the old block
next we got the fifth hokage tsunade the
granddaughter of the first hokage
she's got that powerful sendru and
uzumaki blood in her system
she was regarded as the strongest female
ninja and the best medical ninja
she is respected as one of the saanin
along with jaraya and orochimaru
some highlights include her powerful
physical strength which was strong
enough to
earn praise from madara and to break
through his susano rib cage
the strength of 100 seal is also hyped
because it is a jutsu from the sage of
six paths era
and is believed to be the most advanced
version of chakra control
for a long time the user stores chakra
in one point of their body
then they can release that chakra and it
will give them a huge power boost
tsunade can also use creation rebirth
considered the pinnacle of
medical ninjutsu and the ultimate
regeneration technique
the body's natural cell division is sped
up to the point where the user
immediately heals from any wounds while
the technique is active
however such a broken technique must
have side effects and here
you are shortening your lifespan every
time you use it also we know that
tsunade can summon katsuyu the giant
slug
that can aid her in her healing efforts
lastly i'll mention that even though she
is in her 50s she uses a transformation
technique to make it look like she's in
her 20s this technique will effortlessly
maintain itself even while she's
sleeping
except if she runs out of chakra then we
got hokage number six kakashi hatake the
very cool man known as kakashi of the
shotting god
even though ironically he doesn't have
the shot in god when he's hokage
he was another natural prodigy kakashi
was
all around a strong ninja possessing all
nature transformations and yin yang
released
was said to be more intelligent than
shikamatu and he is also
extremely skilled at taijutsu he had to
replace his signature move lightning
cutter
with lightning release purple
electricity because the former wasn't
safe to use without the shutting gun he
could also summon his pack of dogs
when people from different villages saw
kakashi they would see the similarity
between him and his father
saku mohatake who was feared as konoha's
white fang
i've seen hilarious memes about how
people freak out
at seeing kakashi's white hair and make
the connection with his famous
white-haired dad but never seem to
notice the obvious similarities between
the
blonde-haired and blue-eyed naruto and
his even more
famous blond-haired and blue-eyed dad
minato
the yellow flash and when you think
about it that is a pretty interesting
observation
last but not least you better believe we
got naruto zumaki the nine tails jin
churuki and the son of the fourth hokage
again we're gonna breeze through this
zero to hero ninja who went from being
an outcast to fulfilling his dreams and
becoming the hero of the hidden leaf
naruto is another reincarnation of asura
totsuki
and so was pretty much destined for
greatness even before he became
ajinchuriki
we know him well for his use of the
shadow clone jutsu
the rasengan the summoning of toads his
sexy jutsu
and his sage mode and many nine tails
modes including nine tails chakra mode
kuroma mode tailed beast mode six path
sage mode with nine tail chakra cloak
and most recently the very hype and op
baryon mode
this last form is the strongest we've
seen but burns through chakra real quick
and can ultimately lead to the death of
its user notably it also shaves more and
more of the lifespan off of the opponent
with every touch as well naruto now is
by far the strongest kage on this list
which is not surprising for our shonen
protagonist
and that is it remember if you want the
okay broken down in greater detail you
should check out my specific all seven
hokage and their powers explained video
and don't forget to absolutely destroy
that like button if you enjoyed this
long video
and want to see more like it these
videos in particular take a long time to
make
obviously so it really helps when you
smash that like button and leave a
comment saying you want more and leaving
any suggestions
for future video ideas if we can get 6
000 likes on this one i'll get started
on the next naruto video asap
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future naruto videos
and while you wait for the next video to
drop be sure to check out my growing
naruto playlist
which includes videos about the hokage
otutsuki
uzumaki and much much more and until
next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you